today's topic so
um as you guys might notice preach is
not here today reason being
uh is because i've been feeling under
the weather for last couple days
and so it's been hard to schedule things
in with him you know with his schedule
in mind
so i figured that today because i'm
feeling a little bit better
than i have for the last two three days
i would just kind of make a video that's
been on my mind for some time
i'm just going to share with you guys my
thoughts often
on this channel we talk about
accountability you know
and we look towards other people's
experiences that they have online as
means to
create social dialogue but i don't think
we take enough opportunities to look at
our own
life experiences things that aren't
documented and recognize
ways in which we have been wrong
ourselves
it's very easy to look at any story
that you're telling that you've been
through and kind of paint yourself as a
hero
but you know i'm objective enough to
know that i've done wrong to people
um it's been part of my learning
experience department part of my growing
experience
but doesn't change the fact that i hurt
people and then you know one of the
toughest things that you have to accept
about relationships especially when you
don't have great mentors around to
uh kind of help guide you and and help
recognize where you've been wrong
is that you're going to try things and
you're going to make mistakes and people
will end up hurt by the things that you
do
and so uh in light of always kind of
preaching accountability i thought i
would tell you guys stories in which
ways
i myself um have done wrong to others
and so i'll talk to you guys about my
first relationship
um essentially within this relationship
i cheated and
that's something i didn't want to accept
for a long time
because i think when you view yourself
as a decent person you can't imagine
yourself causing that much harm to
someone else
but i did
the irony kind of it was like there was
nothing wrong with the relationship
it was a great relationship both from
her end and from mine and i'm not saying
this through like
rose tinted glasses like she would
remind me all the time like this was the
first time for her
where she'd been in a relationship where
she could communicate freely that she
could express herself and be heard and
understood and not be judged negatively
where she could
basically share any thought she had and
know that she'd be accepted for who she
was
and i took pride in that i took pride in
fostering that kind of relationship with
her because i know growing up
i never had seen relationships like that
in my personal life i never saw other
people dating
and facilitating that um
and so just knowing that she had that it
did give me a sense of pride
um just for a little bit more context
i was 19 at the time this was my first
dating relationship
experience she was 27 so she was a
little bit older than i was
you guys noticing a pattern for me
and we dated for
a year and a half to two years i don't
know like around that period it was
quite some time i was in the military at
the time and i had to be stationed
in her city and then we kind of met
randomly when she saw me dancing
um and
from there we started dating things were
going really well
you know we had a good relationship by
all standards
and knowing all this some of you be
wondering like abba why did you cheat
um the reason why i did was two reasons
one
uh i was irresponsible selfish and
two um i was younger
and i say i was young because i'd always
come from a mindset
that you know i felt like
i wanted to get laid a lot like there's
no other way around it i wanted to
experience new things i want to do so
much i wanted to
bang all the time i want to do all that
kind of crazy stuff
why because like i said in the previous
video i've always thought of myself as
being unattractive
and so the idea that now that i'm
starting to get to play i'm going to be
locked down a relationship
i'll be honest with you guys it just
didn't appeal to me um
and so knowing that i began looking
elsewhere you know i began doing that
behind her back and
the responsible and selfish part was the
fact that i was doing it behind her back
there's there's no other way around it
and so fast forward a couple of months
later
and she ends up finding out i think like
my computer was open and she saw some
messages
and from there it was pretty much over
um she kind of called it all off
immediately which i commend her for if
anyone
is thinking of breaking off relationship
after someone cheats on you that
aggressively
please do what she did she just caught
all contact
and i tried reaching out to her a couple
times but you know she wouldn't respond
and everything was made much worse
because i think like four or five days
later after i
realized what why she had cut contact
with me
i had been at my work offices and my
office had a lot of females
and we were all going for lunch because
one of her co-workers was going to be
leaving the office so you know take
everyone out for work
and so i'm walking through the city with
these like five women right
and i i remember this so vividly it's
one of those weirdest things that's like
how [ __ ] rand i never run so i'm
walking with these women and she's
inside a cafe with her friend talking
and they both see me and they look at me
and i remember being the biggest piece
of [ __ ] in that moment and i waved at
her
and i kept walking and i knew how it
looked optically even though i was not
romantically involved with any of these
women
it was like a weird metaphor for some of
the sins i had committed
so i just remembers
and you might be wondering like why
would you do such an [ __ ] thing and i
remember
pride i didn't want to admit i was wrong
i didn't want to admit i was bad
and so because of that in that moment i
did
i doubled down i doubled down and
i look back on it every time like what
the [ __ ] were you thinking
um and so yeah me and her you know
didn't have contact with that and and as
i came to realize over the next two
years that i was really wrong with what
i did
i had reached out to her to apologize
tremendously and to say how wrong
i was and she kind of intimated to me
that she understands but she didn't want
anything to do with me
and i understood that
um and there was it was definitely
something
i don't regret leaving that relationship
i regret how i did it i regret hurting
her i regret putting that kind of
potential trauma on her because she
might be leaving that relation thinking
like what's wrong with me and
how am i not good enough and not
realizing like it had nothing to do with
her and her behavior
this was just me not being there at that
time and being irresponsible
and it's hard to convey that to someone
when your actions say something else
but i had to recognize in the ways which
i did wrong and then take that into my
future relationships and be responsible
which is why like now
if i don't see potential with someone
i'll just leave early because i don't
want to
put myself in them through that burden
um but thinking back to it it still
hurts me because she was a tremendously
good person
and there aren't enough words to kind of
say
just how wrong i did her in that regards
and that eats at me um
doesn't keep me up at night but when i
think back to it it's like man i really
did wrong
and there's no way i can fix that um so
i have to just kind of leave that at
that and try to be better
for the future there's no way you can
change what has happened
i ended up seeing her it was like four
years afterwards
i was waiting for a ride to
yeah so four years afterwards i was
waiting for a ride
at a chapters and i was looking out the
window kind of waiting for my ride
and sure enough i see her walk by and i
dropped everything i ran out went to go
talk to her
um because i was just so excited and
she was cordial she was kind but i could
tell she felt uncomfortable
and me tuning into that i recognized i
needed to
keep my distance
but i told her that i'm still sorry
and i'm wishing her the best and she
said she understands she's moved on
which is good in a way
but i think about that often and you
know now that i'm in a different place
in my life
you know where i'm not dating casually
i've
let go of the idea that i want to bang
everything and
i um want a family children all that
stuff kind of
it's been very come clear and concrete
for me for the last year and a half
i think back to that relationship but
i'm like i want that
kind of relationship at this point in my
life so
yeah i think i think when it comes to
this stuff when we're online it's very
easy to cast stones and
and criticize other people uh very
aggressively their character and not
realize that people do have room for
growth people can learn people can be
better
and i'm trying not perfect
i don't claim to be i've done things in
my life where i'm
done bad by people and these are things
i'll be discussing over the next couple
of weeks
where i'm going to share with you guys
ways in which i [ __ ] up so that maybe
you guys can learn from it
and do better uh because other people
ended up teaching me lessons to help me
avoid some negative situations and if i
can impart that on anyone
then i'm happy you know
but um
it's hard to come forth and admit that
you were the villain in any story
but many of us have been it doesn't mean
that you're a villain all the time but
you were a villain in that story
and it's important for us to acknowledge
that it's important for us to
acknowledge the pain that we've caused
others
because if we don't then we gaslight
them and that's a bad place to be
take accountability for your stuff i'm
not saying you got to post on youtube or
facebook but if if you're like me and
and you sometimes criticize other folks
for some of the actions they've taken
also be ready to criticize yourself for
the actions that you've been taking and
be transparent about that
you know show the chinks in your armor
show the ways in which your character is
fallible
you know
we may not be defined by our past but
our past is definitely part of our
journey and there's things that we have
to acknowledge don't just show the good
[ __ ] you know show the bad [ __ ] too
right so
so yeah and you know people ask me why
would anyone ever cheat
people treat for all kinds of reasons
sometimes people cheat because they're
neglected
not ready sometimes people cheat because
they're selfish
sometimes people cheat because they're
impulsive sometimes people cheat
to get back at folks sometimes it's a
combination of multiple things cheating
is a complex thing and it's not
something we should condone
or should we should accept it's
something that we as a society have to
speak about responsibly and understand
that it hurts folks
and that commitment is not just a word
but it is a series of actions
it's a way of life when you commit that
means you're encompassing a whole bunch
of different things that you're going to
do moving forward
so let's let's be honest about these
things i know too many of us are
engaging in bad behavior or have engaged
in bad behavior
that we'd rather keep in the dark and i
think by keeping in the dark we don't
allow for our society to really look at
these things objectively and try to look
at them more compassionately
and see which ways we can allow people
to tell their truth
allow for for for truth and
reconciliation to happen
and for people to start their healing
process
so this is my admission to you guys
you guys can hate it you guys can like
it that's perfectly fine i'm
perfectly open to all kinds of criticism
i i
may be deserving of it but i wanted to
kind of just be candid with you guys
um because if i can
influence anybody in a positive way that
i'm always happy to do so
so that is all for today's video i hope
you guys enjoyed it i hope you guys may
have learned something and
if you guys want maybe you can share
stories in the comments where you guys
have been the villains
and uh you know and then we could have
that discussion
so yeah that's pretty much it for today
[Music]